[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ينتظران الاشاره لبدء نزال لا ينتهي الا
بطرح احدهما ارضى على وقع اهازيجه
وايقاعات المحليه هذا نمط من رياضه
المصارعه راى النور قبل الاف السنوات لكنه
مازال ينتظر اعترافا دوليا به
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عادات وشعوب
اهلا بكم في السودان هنا في العاصمه
الخرطوم يتجمع المئات وسط طقوسا خاصه
لمشاهده مصارعه النوبه او الصراع كما
يسميها اهله مصارعه النوبه رياضه شعبيه
نشات قديما في جبال النوبه وتحديدا في
منطقه كردفان غرب البلاد وتورثتها الاجيال
والقبائل حتى ساره
اجتماعيا وثقيا سودانيا عريقه عاده ما
تقام بطولات مصارعه النوبه في اجواء
احتفاليه لمناسبه نهايه موسم الحصاد ليس
فقط في جبال النوبه بل في كل انحاء
السودان فهذه الرياضه ظلت غريبه على
الخرطوم حتى انتقل اليها افراد من قبائل
النوبه في سبعينيات القرن الماضي قربا من
المعارك الدائره في منطقههم وبداوا
بانشائه حلبات المصارعه الدائريه منذ ذلك
الحين اصبحت مصارعه النوبه رياضه شعبيه لا
تجذب الرجال فقط انما النساء والاطفال
ايضا
مصارعه النوبه نوع من انواع الفنون
القتاليه يقوم على احترام الخصم وتقديره
ويعتمد على الخفه والرشاقه والخداع يرتدي
المصارعون السروال قصيرا ويغطون اجسادهم
بالرمال والرماد الابيض يقفون في حلبه
دائريه ويسعد كل خصم لايقاع الاخر ارضا
لتتم له الغلبه وسط الغناء المشجعين
ورقصهم على اهازيجه وايقاعات محليه
وبما ان النوبيين ليسوا قبيله واحده فقط
تختلف طقوس المصارعه النوبيه اين قبيله
واخرى لكن الاتحاد السوداني للمصارعه سعى
مؤخرا لتوحيد طريقه اللعب عبر وضع قوانين
تحكمها كخطوه الاولى للحصول على اعتراف
دولي بها
رياضه رياضه
اصبحت في السنوات الاخيره تاخذ ابعادا
جديده فقط بدا الثلج
يمارسونها ومهما كان في الاعتراف الدولي
سيبقى النوبيونه اهلا هذه الرياضه واصلها
ومن حافظ عليها وطورتها ونشرها